another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
ending reports with lyrics from the
fresh prince of bel air sometimes work
at the scp foundation can get a bit
grueling so dr bright tries to brighten
everyone's day with a little pop culture
reference or two however after a report
on scp-096's potential origins concluded
with in west of the arctic born and
raised in the mountains is where he
spent most of his days his colleagues
agreed that enough was enough however
after he submitted a formal request he
was given certain allowances mainly he
can use lyrics from safety dance as the
majority of the research staff still
find them funny most notably he ended a
report on scp-049 with you can cure if
you want to you can leave your friends
behind cause your friends got plaguin if
they've got plagued then they're no
friends of mine after his accompanying
dance nearly broke a window and
triggered a containment breach of
scp-173 however his boogeying privileges
were revoked